[MUSIC PLAYING]
OLGA RUSSAKOVSKY: AI4ALL grew
out of my passion and also
my Ph.D. adviser's passion
for diversity and inclusion.
Computer science
is a very, very
male-dominated field.
And for a while, I sort
of handled that by saying,
you know, this doesn't
matter, and sort of gender
doesn't matter, and
diversity doesn't matter.
And actually, it
makes a big difference
to have people
that look like you
and have sort of similar
experiences to you
and that can relate to you.
So I started sort of
appreciating the need for more
diversity at all levels.
If we have people who only come
from certain perspectives, who
were shaped by certain
particular cultures,
that's inevitably going to
propagate into the AI models
that we're actually building.
DENNIS KWARTENG:
ADITHI RAGHAVAN: I go to a
humanities-based school,
and so we do a lot of work
with philosophy and psychology.
And I guess I'm
looking to combine
my passion for
mental health with AI
and hopefully create
a project that
can help others who are dealing
disorders like depression, bipolar
disorder.
I just want to be able to
make it easier for people who
struggle with things like that.
OLGA RUSSAKOVSKY: We really try to
emphasize AI for social good --
AI in health care,
AI in education,
AI for accessibility,
AI for disaster relief,
AI for solving all of these
various challenges and problems
that we face in the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]